5 років нацистської окупації Польщі
в часи Другої світової війни залишили багато ран у Варшаві
Нагадування про цю сумну главу історії міста і через понад 70 років
можна знайти повсюди в польській столиці
Утім, консервативний уряд Польщі стурбований тим
що за кордоном нібито дедалі менше ясності
щодо того, хто був злочинцями, а хто жертвами нацизму
Коли 2012 року президент США Барак Обама обмовився і назвав "Аушвіц"
в Освенцімі польським табором смерті
це стало справжнім скандалом у польсько-американських відносинах
Цей ролик, профінансований польським урядом, має на меті
розставити крапки над і щодо таборів смерті
Англомовний кліп, на який не пошкодували грошей
розміщений на YouTube на правах реклами
покликаний просвітити користувачів у Європі та Ізраїлі
щодо польської історії
Ще більш суперечливим, ніж соціальна медіа-кампанія
виявився новий закон
Цей закон захищає країну й поляків від наклепів
Це ніщо інше
як законодавчо запровадити покарання за заперечення Голокосту.
Досі Німеччина не виплатила Польщі жодних репарацій
за Другу світову війну
Кароліна Вігура спеціалізується на
єврейській історії Польщі
Занадто поспіхом ухвалили новий закон,
вважає вона
До того ж незрозуміло, як його інтерпретуватимуть
Цілком очевидно, що уряд такої реакції не очікував
Закон погано підготували,
не передбачивши можливих наслідків
Це єдина синагога у Варшаві,
що вистояла в часи окупації
До війни у Варшаві мешкали понад 300 тисяч євреїв
Нині їх - менше 10 тисяч
Як єврейська громада ставиться до закону?
Люди тут не почуваються напряму якось обмеженими цим законом
але вони запитують себе,
чи в сучасній Польщі ще є для них місце
Це жахливо, що я вимушений це сказати
Поляки дуже постраждали в часи Другої світової
Були герої - Праведники світу - найкращі люди світу
Але були також окремі поляки, а іноді й групи поляків
які співпрацювали з німцями
і уможливлювали вбивства євреїв
І те, і те є правдою
І в демократичній вільній Польщі ми повинні мати можливість
говорити про це без страху перед юридичними наслідками
Нинішній польський уряд натомість розігрує історичну карту
як найважливіше завдання Варшави